Moi, ce qui m'a toujours
intrigué dans mon métier
c'est toujours d'essayer d'aller voir
ce qu'il y a derrière le mur
là où on voit pas.
Et donc, qu'est-ce qui se passe dans
la tête d'une institution quand elle dort
parce que c'était ça
cette métaphore.
Elle dort et pourtant
il s'y passe des choses.
C'est la première fois
qu'une équipe de tournage
pouvait accéder à des lieux
qui n'avaient jamais été filmés.
Parce que mon objectif,
c'était de ne pas montrer les vedettes
mais de montrer l'ombre.
" La nuit, c'est toujours
un peu particulier.
Alors que Paris dort un petit peu,
ici, c'est la ruche.
Ça travaille.
- Et on peut quelques fois
péter les plombs aussi
donc on ne vient pas
pendant une semaine.
- Avec, ma vie de couple a explosé...
- Par contre, ça nous rajeunit parfois."
Il y a cette femme,
un peu effacée.
Au moment où je l'interviewe,
il doit être minuit
toute seule à la buvette
avec deux hommes
qui sont bien sympathiques
mais je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit super contente d'être là.
Donc oui, la politique
parfois fait des ravages.
Parfois la politique
brise des couples.
C'est aussi un
engagement lourd, lourd...
et évidemment que
les Français ne voient pas.
" C'est par ce tunnel piéton
au troisième sous-sol
que les députés peuvent
rejoindre leur chambre
leur bureau aussi.
- Bonsoir !
Bienvenue !
- On peut se permettre ?
- Bienvenue dans le gîte ! "
Quand vous êtes
un député de la majorité
pour éviter de vous faire
marcher trop longtemps
on vous met
dans l'hôtel et le Palais.
Quand vous êtes un député
de la troisième zone de l'opposition
vous avez le droit au 101
ce qui était le cas
de Jean-Claude Cendrier
quand on a tourné
ce document
député communiste de Bourges.
" C'est moi qui fait
le lit, bien entendu.
Mon pyjama, c'est personne
qui me le met, c'est moi. "
Dans ces lieux,
quand le silence est là
il y a quelque chose,
il y a une énergie.
Et il y a un huissier
de nuit qui m'emmène
dans les combles
du toit de l'Assemblée.
On ouvre des trappes,
on passe, on monte un escalier.
Mais je sens qu'en fait il en
a encore, comme on dit, sous le pied.
Il prend une clé
et il dévérouille un cadenas,
pousse une porte
et nous voilà,
cette fois-ci, sur le toit.
" Dernière serrure à ouvrir avant de
rejoindre le fronton du palais Bourbon.
À plus de 27 mètres
au-dessus du sol,
vue imprenable sur la tour Eiffel
et la place de la Concorde. "
Je me retrouve
à califourchon sur la pointe
avec le drapeau
qui flotte sur ma gauche.
Alors, c'est minuscule
comme joie,
mais c'est une joie
tellement intense d'être là
où personne n'a pu
aller auparavant.